-A lot of people
are still talking about
their New Year's resolutions.
My resolution this year
is to travel more.
Quest, what's yours?
-Hey, I'm gonna go to the gym
more, you know?
My calves are gonna be
as buff as phonebooks.
-Nice. What about you, Higgins?
-[ Coughs ]
-I'm cutting back on smoking.
Now I'm on -- [ Coughs ]
just like three packs a day.
That's it.
-That's good. That's great.
James, what about your
New Year's resolution?
-[ Speaking Na'vi ]
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-[ Speaking Na'vi ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter ]
What?
-Oh, my God.
Okay.
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
He already learned Na'vi.
That's great.
-He speaks fluent Na'vi, yeah.
-He's a whiz with an air fryer.